IT'S TIME TO PLAY VINE-OS.
VINE--OS.
WHEN ARE YOU IN A TOTAL
BLACKOUT THE ONLY THING
BETTER THAN PIZZA IS PUBLISHING
SHORT VIDEOS OF YOURSELF ON
VINE.
WE'RE GONNA SHOW YOU A VINE OF
AN ALLEGEDLY DRUNK PERSON
STRUGGLING TO COMMUNICATE, AND
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TRANSLATE THEIR BABBLE INTO
SOMETHING A SOBER PERSON WOULD
UNDERSTAND. ALL RIGHT.
FIRST ONE, THESE THOUGHT
PROVOKER.
>> -- BE [BLEEP] WITH KEA,
LITTLE [BLEEP]IN ASS [BLEEP].
>> CHRIS: RON?
>> WHAT THEY TRYING TO SAY
IS, HEY, RON FUNCHES, WE'RE ON
OUR WAY OVER, KEEP THAT DICK
HARD.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THESE LOQUACIOUS
LADIES.
>> -- HE'S A REAL HIP-HOP MVP.
>> WHERE IS DENMARK AT?
>> CHRIS: PETE.
>> THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME
OUT OF TAMPA.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE, THIS
PONTIFICATING POET.
>> -- DAWG, GET OFF MY DICK.
JUST SUCK AND RUN.
>> CHRIS: PETE HOLMES.
>> IN 20 MINUTES, I'M GONNA
[BLEEP] TUBA.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
THIS BEER BUD.
>> VINE. VINE! [BLEEP] VINE.
>> CHRIS: YES, RON.
>> DON'T BE RACIST, PRB ISN'T
JUST FOR WHITE PEOPLE ANYMORE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> HEY, MY BROTHER'S THE
@MIDNIGHT CHAMPION RON FUNCHES,
I CAN SAY WHAT I WANT.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
PETE.
>> PABST IS THE ONLY BLUE
RIBBON I'LL EVER WIN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS AGAIN TO PETE.
LAST ONE.
THESE TWO.
>> YOUR MOM-- YOUR MAMA
IS--
>> CHRIS: PETE HOLMES.
>> WE JUST FOUND OUT WE'RE
RELATED BUT IT ONLY MADE THE
SEX HOTTER.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.